Welcome everybody to talks at Google.
We are so happy to have you here.
We're very happy to have our guest here.
Our esteemed guests,
Scooter Braun,
a scooter is one of the biggest entrepreneurs and innovators in entertainment
today.
Uh,
he started as a teenage party promoter is the biggest college party promoter,
uh,
in Atlanta.
While going to Emory,
he leveraged that into a director of marketing position at Soso death in its hay
day.
Uh,
he left,
so,
so def,
uh,
found a little known artist named Justin Bieber.
Uh,
and then basically leverage that into creating,
uh,
the largest,
or one of the largest media empires,
uh,
in,
in music and entertainment today.
Uh,
SB projects covers all media.
It's not just music.
Uh,
so he obviously manages artists like Kanye west,
Ariana Grande Day,
Justin Bieber of course,
uh,
Edm acts like Martin Garrix.
Uh,
and then,
you know,
models like Karlie Kloss.
Uh,
it also has a tech incubator arm called silent labs.
We were just talking about it earlier.
They have really impressive investments and Uber,
Spotify ways,
Pinterest to name a few.
So it's track record.
There is a pretty impressive,
uh,
and he's also all about giving back.
So He's on the,
uh,
board of directors of his brothers foundation pencils of promise as well as his
wife's a foundation.
And a,
I don't think we're allowed to curse here.
So fuck cancer.
There you go.
He went for it and that's his wife yell.
Bron I'm also very impressive in her own right.
Please give it up for Scooter Braun.
Thank you so much for coming.
Awesome.
So I actually want to start,
uh,
with your childhood and just set a little context and I want to start with a a
movie you made a student film,
uh,
when you were in high school,
you made a movie about the Jews of Hungary and this had a special kind of place
in your,
in your heritage and you actually got some recognition from Steven Spielberg on
it.
Is that,
is that correct?
Can you,
can you tell us that story?
Um,
I,
I went to school and uh,
my teacher in middle school said there's something called national history day
and no one from our school has ever,
you know,
gone to nationals.
But if you get to nationals,
there's an all expense paid trip to Washington DC.
And I really wanted to go to Washington DC.
I wanted to see the monuments.
I wanted to see everything I'd seen about it.
So I went home that day and I said,
mom,
I'm going to Washington DC.
And she said,
you're crazy.
She goes,
what are you talking about?
And I came up with this idea.
So my grandparents are Holocaust survivors.
My grandmother was a liberated from Bergen.
Belsen was an Auschwitz and my grandfather wasn't dot Kao.
Um,
and I was always kind of fascinated by the story of how they could just live in
this country and live a normal life like I was living at the time.
And then suddenly their country just betrays them.
And you know,
everyone in their family dies and they're the only survivors.
Uh,
so I decided to do a 10 minute documentary called the Hungarian conflict.
And it was the story of how,
um,
hundreds of thousands of Jews were deported over two weeks voluntarily by the,
the German people and the German army towards the end of the war.
Um,
and submitted it,
won regionals,
one states,
uh,
lost in nationals to a documentary about airplanes that make loud noises and fly
over a neighborhood in Chicago.
Um,
because that is the most important topic.
That can be a story about the Holocaust.
Uh,
I'm not bitter.
I'm 36.
I've let go of it.
Uh,
and,
but actually I had an amazing time.
I got to go down there and made a lot of friends and,
uh,
I was 13,
14 years old and when I came back,
um,
my other grandmother,
my mom's mother,
she was very proud and she sent it in to the Holocaust museum.
And somehow someone,
uh,
got it to Steven Spielberg,
she had sent it to his office,
everyone else,
cause he had the show a foundation.
He was collecting information about Holocaust survivors at the time.
And I had no contact entertainment.
No one in my family had a contact entertainment.
We knew no one in the world right now,
work in.
And one day in the mail,
I get this letter from the office of Steven Spielberg and a letter,
um,
typed out on his letterhead,
signed by him talking about my film and encouraging me to keep going.
And I framed it and it's been on my wall ever since.
When I went to college.
It was on my wall,
it's on the wall in my Home Office now.
Uh,
and it made me believe that I could really achieve anything.
Like if a kid who had no context could get to Steven Spielberg,
I thought,
you know,
anything is possible.
Uh,
and funny enough,
um,
about 17 years later,
I was at the White House press dinner with a client and they moved us into a
private room,
uh,
with celebrities because they didn't want the press.
Just hounding these celebrities in the big room before,
uh,
the event with the president started and Steven Spielberg was in the room and he
started talking to us and I said,
listen,
I don't mean to interrupt,
but I just need to tell you.
Years ago when I was a kid,
I did a video about the Holocaust.
And you,
and before I can get a word out,
he goes,
you didn't do the Hungarian one,
did you?
And he remembered 17 years later and I was completely in shock.
And it's just a testament to who he is and how genuine he is.
And it was just very encouraging.
I still have it on my wall.
Uh,
to this day
you mentioned something pretty remarkable,
which is that you started off knowing no one and entertainment.
Now you'd know everybody in entertainment.
So if the first inflection point was kind of Steven Spielberg giving you
recognition in that giving you kind of the,
just the belief in yourself to do anything after that.
A second inflection point is,
you know,
cut to Atlanta,
uh,
you're throwing parties for,
for rappers like ludicrous and M and.
M.
How exactly did that come about?
Um,
Atlanta
is an,
Atlanta was racist and that's the reason it happened.
I,
uh,
I went down to Atlanta to play basketball and broke my dad's heart cause I took
a d three offer instead of a d one offer because d one said,
hi,
you're five 11 and can't really jump or run that fast.
So nice jump shot,
you're going to sit the bench for the first two years.
And I didn't really like that.
So I was like,
okay,
I'm going to go play d three.
I'm going to get,
you know,
come out and start and get playing time.
And I got down to Atlanta and no one cared about our team and my best friend was
at Duke and he was the star of that team.
And uh,
we played Aau basketball against each other.
So that's how we knew each other.
And um,
when I got down there,
because I came from an Aau basketball team where I was one,
I was a minority on my team.
I was one of three white guys on a majority black basketball team and our team,
since we were 14 years old in our state,
we every weekend,
three to four months out of the year,
we were in hotel rooms together as brothers.
I mean,
these guys are still to this day,
my brothers,
I have to explain to my wife and one of them calls like,
well,
I've never even met this person.
You're just gonna let him sleep in our house.
And I,
you know,
said in my childhood,
this is,
this is family.
Um,
so when I got to Atlanta,
I didn't really have that perspective of white people went to clubs that played
techno and black people went to clubs to play hip hop and there was no mixing.
So I didn't like that.
And I saw an open,
excuse me,
I saw an opening and I needed a,
I need to legit money.
Um,
because I was broke and uh,
selling fake ids was not a longterm plan.
Um,
so I stopped by this club called chaos in bucket,
uh,
back in the day.
And I said,
if you let me bring people here,
would you pay me?
And he goes,
well how many people can you bring?
I said,
how many do you hold?
And he said,
800.
And I said,
that sounds about right.
I didn't know what I was doing.
I went to Kinko's,
I made flyers,
I named my company Kryptonite entertainment cause I like Superman.
Um,
and uh,
I had a bunch of freshmen girls pass out flyers for me cause I had a high school
sweetheart.
So the freshmen girls weren't threatened by me because I would dance and have
fun,
but I wasn't trying to sleep with them because I was loyal to my high school
sweetheart.
And,
uh,
where the freshmen girls tell you to go,
it seems like the rest of the campus went.
Um,
and next thing you know,
I had 800 people there.
And this is a long story,
but,
uh,
sorry for taking so long,
that first party,
um,
someone approached me and he was like,
this party is amazing.
Look at all of these kids,
different diversity,
you know,
listen to hip hop.
And I looked at him,
I was like,
you're Michael Jackson.
And No,
it was not Michael Jackson,
but it was Jason Weaver who played young Michael Jackson and the Ph one movie
that I would watch every single year when they'd play about the Jacksons.
And he was like,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm a on a different TV show now.
That was like 10 years ago,
dude.
And um,
he said,
do you want to see how the other half lives?
And I said,
what do you mean the other half?
He goes,
black people.
And um,
he took me to velvet room on a Tuesday night,
uh,
this,
this guy from members,
old Atlanta,
so the original velvet room.
And,
um,
there's a guy named Alex get a one who is now one of the biggest club owners in
Atlanta who originally started off as an Ethiopian immigrant parking lot
attendant.
And at that point he become a huge promoter.
Uh,
and he had a stutter,
still does.
And he was so fascinated that I was there that he said,
let the white boy and,
and he let me in for free instead of paying the hundred dollars a head cutline
charge.
Um,
and I would put parties on every Thursday for college kids and spend every
dollar of it on Tuesday's meeting.
People basically faking it till I made it.
Um,
and then I bought,
I made so much cash with the parties because Alex really taught me how to
promote.
I learned what I really deserve to make it those parties.
I started making the door part of the bar and he educated me,
uh,
and I bought a purple Mercedes with rims on Ebay
and I started driving that to the party and so I can really floss and get
everyone's attention.
And they were like,
who is this kid?
I was like,
you should come to my parties.
And I said,
we're playing hip hop too.
And I started getting basically all these rappers of Atlanta started coming to
my events and I wasn't paying them and they were coming for free and have a good
time.
And the first artist I ever worked at my parties was,
I'm a DJ in Atlanta called Chris level lava,
who had an alternate personality named ludicrous and he had a record called
throw them bows.
And that was the first record I ever worked.
Uh,
and that's how I kind of got on the scene.
And then one day I'm,
Jermaine Dupri called me and he was,
he came to Atlanta was a big billboard,
used to say,
welcome the homeless.
So,
so death.
And he was on top of his game.
A lot of people don't know this.
Jermaine Dupri is the only producer in music to have a number one on the
billboard charts for 16 years straight,
um,
more than Quincy Jones.
And,
uh,
Jermaine asked me to come meet with him and Jermaine is not a tall man.
So we met and he,
his feet were dangling from this chair and he was talking to me and I was just
so fascinated with his feet,
didn't touch the ground.
Um,
and uh,
and he asked me to come help him run his company and do marketing.
I was 20 years old and I became the vice president of marketing.
It's so set of records.
Amazing.
That was a long roundabout way of answering one question.
No,
he bought what he told me before we started that when it's about Crypto,
this place is packed.
So should we just talk about crypto?
Like you just,
just,
just put the word out.
Just be like,
Yo,
it's not what you think.
It's not about,
not about Kanye and people are,
it's about crypto.
Get in there right now.
We're talking about with theory them.
It's getting crazy in here.
That's awesome.
This is,
that guy has tips.
It's got information on quant stamp.
No,
no ICO talk unfortunately.
But that,
that was incredible.
Uh,
I don't think I've ever heard that story at that level of detail.
So,
uh,
okay.
So you're,
you're,
you know,
a director of marketing at so,
so def,
uh,
talk about your kind of a decision to leave.
So,
so death and then you want the truth to the Nice version.
I want the two of you guys want,
what do we want?
Uh,
how many people see this 700 k subscribers?
Okay,
Justin us.
Um,
but you have finite it,
right.
Jermaine changed my life because he gave me an opportunity and he,
and he knows this.
I actually just was down in Atlanta and we spent the night hanging out together.
Um,
I'm incredibly grateful the guys like him,
Shaka Zulu,
who was ludicrous as manager who put me in a guy named [inaudible] Stewart,
who unfortunately is no longer with us,
who brought me into the music game.
Um,
guys like Steve Rifkind who gave me my first record deal for Asher Roth.
and these,
these guys really changed my life.
But,
uh,
at the time I had all these ideas about social media and how to break acts and
Jermaine wasn't listening to me.
Um,
he was really focused on what he was focused on and just wanted me to kind of
promote what he wanted.
And um,
I had to go to London for something,
something other project I was consulting for.
And while I was over there,
I ran into little job.
And a lot of people don't know this,
but for nine years,
little John worked as an ANR.
It's so sort of records before he became little John and we started talking,
he said,
don't take nine years.
He goes,
I wouldn't have become a little and wouldn't have the success I'm having now if
I took this long.
And we had,
you know,
just had yeah.
With usher and he produced that.
We executive produced that album.
Um,
and that was really resonating in my head.
And when I came back,
I would say I had one foot out the door,
but I was scared,
you know,
I wanted to chase my dreams.
I wanted to pursue what I wanted to pursue.
But I had built this identity at 23 years old over the three years I was at
remain,
you know,
almost 24 at that point.
Um,
and I was afraid of stepping away as much as I didn't want to be there because I
think a lot of people,
you know,
you guys work for a company,
so a lot of you probably have entrepreneurial spirits and want to do something,
but there's something about the steady paycheck that's crippling.
Um,
and Jermaine's mother came into the office,
she had an office,
don't ask why.
Um,
and for some reason that day she was just in a mood and wanted to tell everyone
who worked there that her son doesn't need any of them and he makes all the
money and all you people are just overhead.
And I said,
look,
with all due respect,
I have my own company and promotion separately for this,
but I love your son,
but I don't have to be here.
And I don't really appreciate you saying that.
So could you know,
chill a little bit.
And I was being respectful and she looked at me and said something,
uh,
that out of respect for him,
I will not repeat,
um,
because that's his mom and,
but it was disrespectful and completely inappropriate and hurtful.
And I'm not just to me,
but to people beyond me as an individual.
And,
uh,
I decided instead of saying something back,
I just left.
And when I got back to the office the next day and kind of calm down,
didn't worry about it.
Um,
she had a letter in my mailbox firing me.
and,
but what killed me was it was signed also by him.
So I went over to see him and I'm like,
what the hell?
And he's like,
man,
it's my mom.
Just give you two weeks and I'll straighten it out.
And that was all I needed to know.
Uh,
and I remember taking my car,
driving over to Kroger by my house,
sitting on the hood of my car and realizing as scared as I was,
this was the opportunity actually really did want and the universe forced it on
me.
Um,
and universe has a way of doing that and your life feel like you,
you,
you really want to do something and you're holding back,
holding back and then you think something bad happened.
It's just the university usually correcting something for you.
Um,
and that sent me out on my own track and I,
uh,
I'm grateful she decided to say some crazy shit to me.
Sorry,
Google for cursing again.
You know,
you can search curse words.
Google.
Right.
That's true.
They do show up and you can search them.
Yeah.
You guys actually don't block anything that you're saying.
You can't say that's true.
I actually don't even know what the official policy is.
Well,
my question is,
is,
you know,
especially with so many languages you have around the world.
Yeah.
I would challenge you right now with the cameras.
I want you to pick any curse word you want,
but I want you to say it right now because I want to,
I want to release this for you.
I want to give you,
I want to give you this freedom.
So I'm going to,
we're going to just count to three and you're going to say a curse word.
I'm going to say a curse word.
Yeah.
One,
two,
three shit.
Give him a round of applause.
That was very scary for him.
And I want to let you know that you were let go about two seconds.
You realize I want for the most PG curse where it was pretty,
it was pretty weak,
but it's cool.
Thank you for that.
Skewed it.
Wow.
So we're talking about crypto in here.
That's right.
Get in.
We got scooter coin is coming up actually.
Oh hell no
one will not make it past the bubble.
Um,
okay,
so you leave.
So,
so def,
uh,
kind of an abrupt ending there.
Uh,
talk about the time in between.
So,
so def and finding Justin Bieber and then how exactly you found Justin Bieber on
youtube,
right.
Thanks guys.
Well done.
Um,
yeah,
that worked out well for me.
Just a grown man in the middle of the night and his underwear,
the internet staring at little boys singing and look at my life now.
I wasn't even arrested.
It was good.
Um,
actually I have to get,
that's not true.
I
got arrested in Long Island for Justin,
so maybe that was the reason I'm going to ask about that later.
Yeah,
that was just a mall that things are crazy.
I was the first arrest in US history for refusing to tweet Jesus.
Um,
long story.
We don't have to go there.
You guys can look it up.
My records expunged so I can get global entry again.
It's awesome.
Um,
all right.
In between,
I,
uh,
I needed a calling card,
so I went back to the original guy,
ludicrous.
A bill O'Reilly.
Um,
he had said ludicrous as a gangster rapper and,
and you know,
companies shouldn't work with him.
And suddenly companies believe Bill O'reilly for some reason and ludicrous,
lost all his endorsements,
Pepsi,
everything.
Um,
and I was like,
if you guys give me a shot,
I'll find you something.
And he was in an amazing movie called crash that was coming out.
Uh,
and my buddy knew someone at Pontiac and said,
hey there,
you know,
maybe go there.
They're doing the solstice.
I heard they have a budget.
So I called pretend I was in a college report or trying to do,
how do you guys do endorsement deals?
And they told me the name of their agency.
I went to the agency and said the same thing,
I'm a college kid doing a report on this,
would you like to speak to me?
And,
um,
got to the woman,
said,
look,
there's no report here.
This is what it's really about.
And she goes,
I don't know about ludicrous.
And I said,
look,
come to the premiere of crash with me and if you,
you'll see.
And when she saw crashed and saw him in it,
she said,
I love this.
And we did a deal for the Pontiac solstice.
Uh,
I took his song two miles an hour.
Um,
I've never told this story,
so this is,
I'll never get another deal Pontiac after I tell this.
Uh,
so like I said,
I really have anything,
like I was kinda going week to week still.
They started throwing parties again to kind of get paid.
Um,
and um,
I got them to agree to let us shoot the video with one of our music video
directors and we would make a music video with the Pontiac solstice and then
give them 30 seconds,
a minute clips to actually make it to their commercial.
And it was a huge $10 million campaign.
Uh,
but the Pontiac at the time was still a prototype,
like they hadn't started sending out the actual cars.
So you know anything about cars.
The prototypes are like $2 million each because it's not the actual car,
it's the model.
Um,
so we needed it for the video.
So they send it bent down and you're not supposed to drive it.
It drives,
it's a car,
but you know,
it's a $2 million prototype car.
But I didn't have money to put it on a flatbed and take it across town.
So I drove the $2 million car down the highway,
literally like freaking out the whole way and got it to the video.
And to this day,
no one knows I did that.
Um,
but now it's 800,000 people just found out.
Uh,
and that was kind of my calling card.
And people are like,
this is before Jay z had to deal with Nike and you know,
rappers and hip hop didn't really have endorsement deals.
So people started hearing about the fact that I was able to pull it off.
And then,
um,
I did a party for him,
uh,
for the anger management or with Anam and got showtime to sponsor it with their
show soul food.
And I started using this as a calling card and I was doing consulting and
marketing for hip hop and R and B acts all over Atlanta and then around the
industry.
And I decided I'm gonna Start my own company because of all these ideas about
social media.
And I found a kid on my space name Asher Roth,
um,
who didn't even have a mix tape out,
but I just liked his lyrics and I had an idea about,
you know,
a part of rap that it's very common now but wasn't being represented at the
time.
Um,
cause you had M and m and that was just it from,
you know,
white boys.
Uh,
and flew Asher down to Atlanta,
got him to move on to my couch and we just started that process.
Then I got him a house around the corner.
They was like filled with rats and got my old college djs when I was a big part
of weren't in college.
They were two guys that were,
I'm going to Clark and Morehouse and that was Dj,
um,
trauma and DJ cannon.
And they had become big mix tape Dj.
So I got them to do a mix tape for Asher cause we kind of came up together.
And when Ashley Rhode Island College for months after finding Asher,
I found Justin [inaudible] on Youtube,
flew him in his mother down on the first plane ride.
Either of them had ever been on,
put them illegally,
uh,
Donald Trump into,
um,
into house.
It's Canadians.
He's not as threatened.
Uh,
uh,
we can talk about it all that later and uh,
had them living around.
And when we wrote aisle of college,
Justin was actually sitting there as a 14 year old kid.
And,
um,
it was kind of this little family unit that we had.
Um,
and uh,
since I see like a lot of young people here,
uh,
strange,
I didn't know Google had so many young employees.
Uh,
just it's so against your reputation.
Um,
and
I was 25.
I had Justin living in a townhouse under my name with Aaron's rents,
furniture that I bought.
Um,
and Asher living in a house around the corner from him and this decrepit rat
filled the house with his buddies that just came with him and dropped out of
college with him.
Um,
and I had my apartment and I had money for 13 months before I went broke and I
wasn't doing parties.
I was pot committed.
I was in it,
burn the ships,
I was there.
And that was that.
And I was in a month 11 my dad called me just to try to check out.
And I remember being 25 and just breaking down hysterically crying on the phone
saying I'm a failure.
And nobody in Atlanta knows,
everyone thinks I'm killing it.
Everyone thinks I'm doing it.
And I'm two months away from losing it all and I haven't done anything with you
know,
for these guys yet.
And he goes,
well,
you've come this far,
two more months to see what happens in the next day.
Asher,
Rhode Island College.
Um,
and within the two months I was able to pull off hyping a publishing deal at
south by southwest.
Um,
I had one publisher meet me at a restaurant across the street from the other,
so I made sure they saw each other and created a bidding war.
Uh,
got Asher a million dollar pub deal.
Took the commission to that,
saved my company and never look back.
And that's,
that's pretty much the way I would describe to you.
That's how close failure and success actually are.
There's a very fine line.
And to get to success you have to walk right next to failure.
And um,
I've paid for pizza would change.
I've cried on the phone at 25 years old and it's funny,
actually think I'm 36 now.
It's been 11 years and my life is very different.
Um,
and I'm glad I learned that lesson.
This is awesome.
This might be the most candid interview I've ever given,
so I appreciate you better than my brother.
Yes.
I don't know.
I can't,
no,
I can't say yes.
You say yes,
it's on record.
Sorry Adam,
if you're watching,
I'm sorry.
I mean,
he did great.
He,
he interviewed my brother and in SF last week,
last week,
a few weeks ago,
three weeks ago.
My brother is very impressive.
He's mom's favorite.
I'm older.
He's a lot more impressive.
Uh,
if you guys could look into mission,
you or pencils of promise or the fact that at 32,
he was the UN global education crisis committee head.
Um,
yeah.
He's like,
yeah,
he's like,
that guy is 100% mom.
Mom loves him and my sister mom loves even more than,
it's not even close.
He says he gets very competitive with you in basketball.
Yeah,
I mean our dad's a coach so we like grew up playing competitive basketball whole
lives and Adam is a better athlete and definitely has a better handle.
Um,
but he's jumped shots week.
I definitely have the best jumps in on the family.
He won't contest that.
But that's all I got taken shots.
But it's real and that's good.
And as you get older,
like my game is more efficient because as you get older and you have a jump
shot,
you can survive three point line.
The three point line.
I like how there's like three people in here who are basketball fans and
everyone else's.
Get back to the crypto talk bro.
Get back to the crypto w we have more velvet room goers
then basketball fans.
Uh,
okay.
So that's,
that's crazy.
It's almost like Asher gave you the runway to do what you did with Justin,
which is maybe a little known fact,
which is that,
that's pretty incredible.
When you,
when you saw Justin,
uh,
on Youtube,
you flew him out,
you flew him and his mother out,
and you've got this,
this trial period and you got them to take a chance on you.
How did you know,
like this kid special?
Just from seeing him,
you know,
on,
on Youtube,
you know,
a manager of a great new rising artists actually came to see me last night in my
house and it was our first time meeting and kind of just wanted to get to know
each other and we were talking,
he's a really good dude.
And we were talking about,
you know,
data and different things.
And I just looked at him,
I said,
look,
I remember,
um,
when Sean Parker woke me up one night to tell me that he was going to create an
algorithm for a hit song.
And you know,
it's not the first time I'd heard something like that.
You know,
when you asked me how did,
I know
I like going with gut,
that is a great thing.
But going with gut is a much better way to live.
And if everybody could take data and figured out then,
then there would not be,
you know,
hit songs.
There wouldn't be,
you know,
movies there were,
there wouldn't be innovation.
We would just be following data and following some kind of timeline of how we're
supposed to do things.
And then,
uh,
you know,
there's no,
there's no sensation of discovery.
And I think data is very important because you can learn from it and you'd go
with it.
But if you go through life,
I mean,
everyone in this room will understand this.
If someone gives you a ton of data,
but your gut just tells you it's wrong,
but you follow the data and it's wrong,
you're miserable.
You are like,
I knew it.
I absolutely knew what this drives me crazy.
But if you go against the data and you follow your gut and you're still wrong,
you actually don't feel bad.
You're like,
you know what?
I tried,
I went with my gut.
And what's the point of really doing anything?
The real point is being content and finding happiness,
um,
because you can win a hundred times and not find happiness and then even more
depressed.
So I just think going through life and going with gut is the best thing.
And when I saw Justin,
my gut went off and I actually saw from start to finish how to take this kid on
youtube.
But when I showed other friends that were like cute kid,
but I don't get it,
I knew exactly how to make him one of the biggest pop stars ever.
Like I,
it just,
it all like flew in and I am a spiritual person.
So I think it was someone upstairs that kind of gave me that plan.
Um,
and,
and then I use data,
then I use youtube.
I knew I had to convince people who didn't think the way I thought.
So I was like,
okay,
I'm going to use the data from Yuzu tube and the analytics that youtube is now
sharing with me and you know,
and I'm going to prove it to the naysayers of I'm going to take him some 60,000
views to 66 million here that my nose is itching like crazy.
And in Los Angeles or New York,
when you itch your nose,
people completely get the wrong idea.
Yeah.
I just want to say I live a healthy life.
Just,
just have some allergies.
I'm not,
I'm not that entertainment guy.
Just want to itch the dose scooters sober and lucid right now.
Yeah.
Oh,
very honest.
The only way to go through life.
Uh,
wow.
Ariana Grande's in my mind is probably the closest thing we've seen to Mariah
Carey since Mariah Carey where I carry,
he's just so,
so def artists back in the day,
um,
talk about how you met her and got her to sign on board and then your journey
with,
she was never so SUDEP just clue heat.
Jermaine produced her album.
Oh,
I didn't get produced emancipation
of Mimi velvet room guy knows too.
I wasn't gonna crap to you or when I was like,
now I'm gonna correct.
You know,
way more about this and be a,
okay.
Got It.
Um,
it's been a big mistake.
We're going,
but how did you meet Ariana?
How'd you get her to,
how'd you convince her to sign on board and that and then talk about the
journey.
Cause she,
she left and came back.
Um,
I saw Ariana on youtube do a cover of a Justin Bieber song while she was playing
a secondary character on a Nickelodeon show.
And I was blown away by her voice.
Uh,
and I was like,
this girl is a star and I wanted to meet her and I couldn't really get to her.
And then I saw that she wanted to make music.
So I reached out to a buddy and I was like,
look,
I know I might be a jerk because now she's want to make music and I'm ever reach
out before,
but I've wanted to for a long time.
And it turned out that she had been wanting to meet me for a couple of years and
people that she was asking me to set up were kind of blocking it because they
didn't want me in.
They wanted to be in.
And,
uh,
we met and completely hit it off.
And I said,
let's do this and one on this.
Amazing,
uh,
Ronnie,
what shocked me is that,
um,
Nickelodeon had to deal with Sony and I was like,
how are you not signed to Sony?
And it turns out she said,
Hey,
I want to make music.
And they heard her saying,
and they were like,
well,
she's not a star.
We're not going to give a record deal.
And Sony actually passed on Ariana,
um,
their loss,
our game.
And we did the deal and we started working together and we had two number one
elms.
Uh,
and as you can see on the stage,
I don't really hold my tongue.
Um,
and you know,
there were some other people in her life that were,
um,
kind of as you become more and more popular and famous and more success,
people just start showing up and they want to create dissension because they
want to create opportunities for themselves and their people that were creating
dissension between she and I.
And instead of just kind of succumbing to that,
I,
you know,
said what I felt.
And I'm in that confusion.
We went separate ways.
And,
uh,
six months later when those people show their true colors,
um,
she called me up and she said,
can we,
can we meet?
And we met up and we kind of stayed cordial.
Um,
and it was,
it was nothing.
It was a hug,
forgiven,
you know,
forgive each other for anything that was said and back to it.
And then we had incredible success.
And then,
uh,
and,
and then I'm sure your next question is,
we went through some really trying times together.
Yeah.
And talk about a switching,
switching actually to,
uh,
to Kanye.
Oh,
I thought you'd go there.
Well actually,
yeah,
I should go there.
That you kind of Stevie off.
Well,
uh,
did it,
can you talk about those trying times story on him?
Look,
yeah,
glad you asked.
Um,
I didn't see that coming.
Uh,
Ariana very well known had a terrorist attack at a show in Manchester.
Um,
and over 20 people were killed,
including a nine year old girl and other kids and uh,
and she was there and these people were there to see her.
And there's that guilt you carry when that happens.
Um,
and I was angry because of my grandparents were Holocaust survivors.
I always knew that kind of evil existed in the world.
Um,
and I kind of waited my whole life or an opportunity to take it on.
So I was like rewritten and ready to go and fill with anger.
And I was like,
we're going to do a show,
we're going to go back.
And when I got to her the next day,
she rightfully so was torn apart and she was like,
I don't know if I could ever sing these songs again,
let alone go on stage.
Uh,
so I had to kind of pull myself back and realize this wasn't a moment for me.
Um,
and I worked on canceling the tour or worked with our insurance team and they
insurance company was British and they completely understood and actually said,
we're going to pay the full fee for all her shows for the rest of the tour.
We're going to fully cover the insurance and think about that.
So now she's getting her full fee,
but she doesn't have to pay for production,
should pay for the costume shop,
pay for staff.
She's actually going to make more money by not performing for the last two
months than she would on the hire tour by just accepting the insurance.
Um,
and by the time I flew home,
two days later,
I got home to 16 text messages saying,
call me,
call me.
And I called her up and she knew that financial point and she said,
um,
if I don't do something,
I'm not who I say I am.
And all these kids who come and see me and all the things I tell them,
they're not real.
So what's the plan?
And uh,
I said,
look,
I,
she goes,
I'm ready to go on tour tomorrow.
I want to go back.
And I said,
look,
I think you need to take some time to make sure you're strong enough.
Cause I think you're excited right now,
but let's go back in two weeks because that's Paris.
We'll cancel six shows because you need time to heal and really take this in.
And Paris is where the eagles of death metal happened.
And I thought that was a great statement.
And I said,
but I have a crazier idea before Paris.
Instead of waiting three,
four months a year,
we should go back to Manchester and perform.
And she goes,
do you think so why?
And I said,
because the reason terrorist do this is they want to change our way of life.
They want to scare us.
And the best way to stop it from happening again is answering right away and
answering and defiance and letting them know they're not going to change our way
of life.
And she,
without even pausing was like,
I'm in.
And A,
we had two weeks,
we put the show together and I put a tremendous amount of pressure on a small
Italian girl shoulders.
And um,
and she stepped up and she handled it.
And there were a lot of amazing people who stepped up for that show.
And that will always go down in my mind is the most important and most
incredible show I've ever been a part of.
To give you a little context,
we finally got back to the UK.
We were hurting the night before staying in Manchester.
We rehearsed at Wembley arena the night before and that night was the night of
the London Bridge attack.
So the second terrorist attack happened the night before our show.
Wow.
Um,
and that was the first time I was thinking is my excitement and arrogance going
to get people killed.
And before I could even think about canceling the show.
Chris Martin from Coldplay who was in the show sends me a text,
please don't cancel.
And then Marcus Mumford calls me,
cause I had just seen him in rehearsal and it says,
do not cancel.
It's more important ever that you guys do this show.
Arianna,
I never even talked to about do you even go there?
She had already gone to sleep and uh,
I spent the night,
talked to her mom,
we decided to go on with the show and the Greater Manchester Police wanted me to
release a statement on behalf of our team that the show was going to go on.
I spent the whole night riding it,
woke up,
put it out.
And I said that we have a greater responsibility now more than ever to continue
on this journey.
And you know,
not only for the victims of Manchester,
but the victims of London to honor them and be on that stage.
Um,
and then the Manchester Police put out a statement saying the show will go on,
however,
please understand that the alert is now at high,
which means there's likely going to be an attack.
And we were going to be on youtube.
Thanks.
Uh,
Facebook,
Twitter,
a capital radio,
BBC radio,
and the BBC so you could watch our entire show from your home.
I was convinced no one was going to show up.
And when Marcus walked out,
um,
to open the show,
mom Mumford guys at weren't in town.
It's the only time Marcus Mumford has ever performed without Mumford and sons.
And he did Tim Shell.
And he changed a couple of lyrics to honor the victims.
And when he walked out,
there were 60,000 people in the place.
It was packed and it was chills because it was going about to be a three,
four hour show.
And he and I talked beforehand about what,
how to start it.
And we asked for a moment of silence and at the end he said,
let's not be afraid.
And the place roared.
And it's something I'll never forget for the rest of my life.
That's incredible.
That's awesome that you guys were able to stay the course,
make it happen.
Yeah.
Give it up.
Okay.
So,
uh,
I want to talk about Kanye.
Uh,
you,
you've had a relationship with Connie for a while,
but you signed them kind of later in his career.
Uh,
can you talk about,
uh,
what,
what Kanye means to you as,
as a,
as a friend and as and as a,
you know,
colleague now,
um,
and yeah.
What the future holds for Kanya
look.
Um,
he is the most interesting person I've ever met in my life.
Uh,
he is a genius and I've witnessed and experienced that he truly is a creative
genius cause all my other clients,
you know,
a lot of it kind of comes on the creativity,
the ideas,
like a lot of it myself and team members,
like it's on us to kind of come up with and then work with them.
Connie is always the person.
He's like,
yeah,
I like that,
but what about this?
And you're like,
Damn,
how did I not see that?
Um,
but he's even made me see colors differently.
Like,
I,
I've,
you know,
we've spent so much talking about colors and palettes that I actually see colors
in aesthetic differently because of his education of hours and hours and hours
of conversation.
It doesn't,
he have like Synesthesia,
like,
like yes,
he downs or Cully when he hears sounds,
he sees colors crazy.
Um,
and we were friends for a long time.
Uh,
if you look up the ludicrous standup video,
I am the promoter club owner jumping around,
dancing in it.
And um,
Kanye produced that song.
He makes a cameo in it and we actually met then before he had just signed to the
rock and he was a producer and no one knew who Kanye West was other than,
you know,
if you'd work them as producer.
And we met on that set and we're friendly and kind of over the years,
always knew each other.
His original manager,
John Monopoly was always good to me when I was a younger guy.
Um,
and then when he put up a tweet saying he was $52 million in debt,
he's my friend.
So I texted him,
are you okay?
And,
um,
I guess a lot of people didn't ask him if he was okay.
So he called me back just to talk.
And after talking for about an hour,
he said,
you know,
you need to come work with me.
And I said,
Connie,
we've talked.
We talked about this before.
I don't want to do that.
Like I'm afraid of working with you because I don't want to lose the friendship.
I love you dude,
not on it.
You need to come work with me.
You need to manage me,
know I'm gonna call it as you need to manage me.
And I said,
no,
we're,
we're good.
Why don't we,
when are you back?
You're back in a week.
Okay,
you're back in a week.
We'll talk about it then.
And I thought,
this is like the eighth time he and I have had a conversation like that.
Like,
we're going to get it,
we'll stay friends.
The next morning I got a call from Adidas and Def Jam.
So we're told you the manager and to deal with you.
And that is how I became Kanye West furniture.
Um,
but he's become like a brother.
And I joke around that it's been two and a half years now.
And you know,
I think we'll always be friends and we'll always find ways to work together
because we both have this feeling of like art can change the world.
Um,
and I joke around all the time that,
you know,
I'm his manager today,
but I might not be tomorrow.
Like I've lasted longer than most.
Um,
but you know,
I'm going to be with him next week and saw him last week and it's,
he knows it.
He's like,
someday when you're older,
you're going to say you manage Kanye West.
And that's cool.
And I'm like,
it's cool right now,
bro.
I mean,
we walked in,
you were like,
nice,
easy.
So I was like,
you're God damn right.
It's like I got a hookup.
Yeah.
But he,
he really is a genius.
And here's the thing I like to say about it publicly because I don't like to
talk about it too much publicly.
Out of respect for,
that's not really his thing.
Um,
but Kanye west is the best listener of any artist I've ever worked with.
That's incredible because I feel like that's probably the biggest public
misperception.
She biggest misperception.
Kanye wants the information,
he wants to learn everything.
If you interrupt him and say,
Hey,
my bad,
he goes,
no,
no.
What did you want to say?
He wants.
He's the best listener of anyone I've ever worked with.
Hands down.
And he's also someone who doesn't keep me on the phone and if I say,
Hey,
my kid needs me,
I'll call you right back.
No problem.
Like he's actually incredibly in his own way,
empathetic and considerate,
and is a really,
really,
really good listener.
When he gets frustrated,
his passion might take over and he goes,
what I call full Yay.
But he has a heart of gold and he really is an amazing listener.
And that is,
yeah,
I think 100% the base misconception,
I'm going to name some people you've worked with and you just give me the first
word that pops into your head.
Okay.
Justin Bieber.
Why did hair come to the first thing?
I come back.
Not that that's a,
that's family.
Usher also family.
Um,
brother
Karlie Kloss
kindness Martin Garrix wild man.
Bloodpop Lauren's
also jumping to your pool,
fully clothed.
Um,
blow pop.
Uh,
brilliant.
The won the won it.
I'm glad you came.
Uh,
Kanya last one.
Genius.
Love it.
Okay.
Arianna,
I didn't ask Ariana.
Ariana brave.
Awesome.
Um,
and it feels like right now you represent mostly pop.
Would you say you came from a hip hop background?
Uh,
yeah.
W W how do you,
how do you reconcile that?
Do you want to,
you know,
do more hip hop stuff or
I am in business with more hip hop people then I let know publicly and I'm also
in business with a lot of country music that I don't talk about publicly are our
company has,
um,
a branch of it that owns a piece of a bunch of other companies within our
business.
So we own 50% of a lot of other companies.
We just don't talk about it publicly and allows me to touch other genres,
be involved with other genres.
Um,
and you know,
we've done Edm,
we've done country.
Um,
but there's people that,
you know,
they'll see me at shows and be like,
I don't know,
you're friends with this person.
And you know,
sometimes I'm in business with them as well.
But,
uh,
it's funny because probably of any manager of music history I probably done,
I've put myself out there probably the most because I thought it was a new world
and you know,
if you can create a brand for yourself,
then you can launch other brands and social media was changing things.
So I made a conscious decision to do that knowing that it would put a target on
my back and it would be something people used to criticize me and kind of judge
my character and assume that,
you know,
people that don't know me,
they might assume,
oh,
he's doing that because he wants to become a public figure or be consumed by
that.
And the truth is the majority of the successes we have,
we'll never speak about.
Um,
and the majority of my public life,
my private life isn't very public.
I choose to like show my family in certain aspects,
um,
publicly only because when I came into the industry,
you know,
fast women fast cars was a stigma that you thought of when you thought of a
successful entertainment,
you know,
man.
And uh,
I wanted to change that paradigm.
I want,
I want people to see me and I want them to know you can have success in this
industry and be a good husband,
a good father,
a good friend of family,
man.
And I also think,
especially with what I'm seeing now with time's up in the me too movement,
that,
you know,
this movement can't just be about women.
This movement needs to be about moving the needle on men in the industry so they
treat women better.
And um,
and I think
the only way you do that is you,
you move the needle on what a man's goal is.
If you,
if you tell a young man coming in industry that success doesn't look like that,
that's actually not a good result.
Success is being someone who is honorable to women in someone who's honorable to
their family and honor roll to their commitments of family,
then I think you're going to see more young,
young men not acting so on appropriately and becoming like the generation that
we're seeing fall right now.
And that is something I want because I was raised by a strong woman and I
married one.
So you know,
I,
I don't,
I don't want the next dude coming up looking at my success and thinking,
oh,
I want that car and I want,
you know,
that young girl,
like,
no,
that's not what it's about.
That's actually,
that's a very shallow life in my opinion.
Sorry,
I talked about this too long.
Well,
you're a good role model.
No,
that's great.
Uh,
you talk about a lot of your success going kind of unspoken and,
and unrecognized or you kind of keeping silent about it.
Fittingly you're the tech arm of SB projects is named silent labs.
Can you talk about,
you know,
we were talking earlier just the history of your involvement with tech to the
extent that you can talk about that.
Um,
so the itch came because when I was a big college party promoter,
Emory was one of the first eight schools to launch the Facebook.
And I was like,
what a great way to get my parties out there without having to hack the school
database.
Um,
so I got in touch with the contact page and the master of Dungeon ceremonies,
Mark Zuckerberg or whatever the hell it said at the time.
And he me back,
please talk to it's Wardlow who I saw was the master of coin a or something like
that.
And um,
Eduardo and I for about four months,
negotiated 10% of Facebook for $100,000.
I still have the email,
dear scooter.
Mark wants to launch 32 smaller schools in two weeks.
So unfortunately at this time he refuses to take any outside investment.
Let me know if you're coming to Boston so we can catch up and see if there's
other stuff we can do together.
Now I joke around in my head that I know I'm a closer and if I would've gone to
Boston,
I probably would have closed that deal.
But remember the high school sweetheart I told you about?
Well,
she ripped my heart out and she went to BC.
So the idea of going to Boston and running into her,
it was not happening.
So I was like,
aw man,
screw this Facebook thing.
I'll have to find another way to promote my parties.
And a year later,
it was like Peter Teal invested million dollars for 10% of Facebook.
And I was like,
I could have made $1 million.
Uh,
that's an unprofitable breakup.
And,
but I didn't know what it was going to be,
so I can't claim credit.
But when it continued to becoming this giant conglomerate,
it made me say,
well,
there was something there.
And it actually made me start investing in tech very,
very early before kind of the music industry in La wanted to start going up to
the valley.
I started going up and not really telling anybody because I didn't want anyone
else going up.
Um,
so I was able to get in early in a lot of really amazing companies and they were
personal investments for me.
And then we had our incubator,
if I wanted the company to invest as well.
Um,
but I was able to,
you know,
I went up and I was meeting with another company and they ordered me an Uber and
I'm like,
what the hell is this?
And I'm like,
it's a new thing here in San Francisco.
It's really cool.
And then a friend of mine said,
Hey,
I met this guy,
Travis,
and I have this great picture of Travis in my living room here in la pitching me
about Uber coming to La.
And I was already an investor when it was just in San Francisco,
um,
and you know,
seeing that whole thing.
And,
uh,
then his competitor came up,
which I got into also,
which,
you know,
made him mad at me for a little while.
Um,
but John's number went to my high school.
Shawn Zimmerman was the same age as my brother.
He played soccer when my brother and when that thing happened,
um,
at first it was Zimride and I basically passed because I was an Uber Guy.
But later on,
um,
I had some frustrations and I decided,
you know,
John,
okay,
you know,
let's go do this too.
And um,
I was on a 30 under 30 list and billboard when I was 27 there was a 24 year old
kid on the list and I called a billboard,
Bill Ward,
who was the editor and I say,
can I have the name and number of every single person on the list?
Because I feel like my peers are the people that I want to grow with.
Not Somebody I aspire to be like,
we're going to come up together.
Cause whenever you meet someone powerful,
they say,
oh,
of course I know them,
I'll call them.
We've known each other 30 years.
And you realize that the people sitting next to you when you're working your way
up are the people that you actually going to need when you get there.
Um,
so I called everyone in the list and one of them was a young guy from Sweden
with a startup that was Justin the Sweden.
We became friends and um,
he let me invest in his startup called Spotify.
Um,
and you know,
along the way,
different friends got me into different companies and uh,
um,
it worked out.
You make it seem easy,
like you were like accidentally friends with all the that's crazy.
No,
it lives in,
I just think,
uh,
I don't really think I'm that good at this stuff.
I really think I'm really lucky.
Like when I was a kid and I didn't do homework,
that'd be like a freak snow day because I got a lot of friends who work really,
really hard and they just can't catch a break.
And I'm the dude who goes on the Internet in the middle of the night,
fine.
Justin or my friend sends me a funny video of an overweight Asian dude dancing
and I'm like,
Ooh,
it's like the mock rain.
I'll sign that.
And it's gotten them style and like,
you know,
it's,
the things that are happening may in my career,
it just doesn't really make sense.
So I don't really think it's on me.
I think somebody,
I'm going to get real spiritual on you guys,
but I actually really believe this because when you cry to your dad at 25 and
then you wake up 11 years later next to who I get to wake up with,
with my two kids and my life,
you can't just sit there and be like,
okay,
this is normal.
It's cause it's not.
So I believe that you get blessings to give them to other people or otherwise
you stop getting them.
That's actually my personal belief and I believe as long as we keep doing
philanthropy,
as long as we keep giving back,
as long as we wake up every day and find a way to make sure somebody else gets
an opportunity than somebody upstairs keeps opening the door for more
opportunities.
And that's just my personal belief and either are really shitty people who get
to win along the way.
I'm not interested in,
in like paying attention to them.
I,
we just got to do what we do.
It's beautiful.
Uh,
do you have time for a couple of questions from the,
I got time for whatever this is.
We didn't know how,
what,
how long is this going to be and where's originally we planned this,
we didn't know we'd be in our new office in Santa Monica so we thought coming
out here was going to take hours so I don't really have anything to do for
another hour.
So uh,
and Zach has my phone so I have no idea how many clients have called.
Well,
I'm up here and I'm actually really enjoying the fact that I don't have a phone.
This is like when I went to burning man,
Google burning man,
do you have anything?
But this is nothing like when I went to burning man,
they do,
they do say burning man is the new Davos though.
Like it's all just tech exec.
So I liked it.
I rode a bike around,
I don't do drugs.
And for those people have this stigma that you do drugs of burning man.
Not True.
I don't do drugs and,
but I do ride bikes and I rode a bike around that desert.
Like I was 15 years old at Babel street park.
My phone wasn't on,
I was a wild man.
I was running that thing straight into the oblivion and it was awesome.
So if you like bike riding,
I will tell you there's a great trail.
It's called burning man.
Okay.
I'm going to give,
I'm
going to pass this mic around for audience Q and.
A.
Um,
before I do,
do you have anything you want to like plug or promote that SB has going on?
I'm good.
You guys are Google.
You don't need anything from me.
You got a tea tea shop in your office.
That's part of the fun and feel free to pass it to them.
Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
Diana scar.
Thanks for being here today.
You are an amazing storyteller.
Learn so much.
Just from listening to you,
you've talked a lot about using technology like social media to discover new
music and new artists.
Thoughts on super new technology that could be,
that could potentially be used to discover new music like robots,
self driving cars,
drones and it gives some context.
I work at Google X,
I'm just
blockchain.
Okay.
Watch.
And um,
technology is actually always shaped how we see the music industry.
So like before Tesla,
um,
really created what we know is radio today,
there was no music industry because there wasn't a way to distribute.
So technology actually was the creation of the music industry.
And then if you look at,
um,
you know,
whether it be vinyl and then the adaption to eight track and then cds and
cassettes and all these different things,
and then going to MP three and now streaming technology has always built,
lifted and save the music industry.
Uh,
I have no idea what it's going to be next.
I know that I think we're actually in the infant stage of streaming because if
you actually look at it and we're like,
oh my God,
this person sold 5 million albums,
that's mind blowing.
But the amount of people on the planet that listening to music that actually
isn't mindblowing,
we've never created a way where when there's such a great separation of wealth
in this world to be able to distribute music properly amongst all people.
And now we have streaming,
which is changing that.
Um,
so I don't really know necessarily what's next.
I know.
I think we're in round one.
I mean it's,
I think it's eight point $6 billion.
It's streaming's not creating for the industry,
which has brought it back up to where it was and a little bit above.
Um,
I think we're in literally the first inning of a nine inning game of streaming.
I think it's,
it's going to take the value of music up in a way we haven't seen before.
Um,
and then I think as far as AI
is the most interesting part for me because that's how we're getting a lot of
this playlisting and everything else is becoming so influential.
But I still think it's missing the human touch.
Um,
because AI can kind of identify what songs go together or how we put stuff
together.
But the human touch can identify a human's interaction with music in a timeline
of life.
Because if I say to you,
um,
tell me what you were doing when you were 11 years old,
you're probably not going to your,
maybe there's something influential happening I live on,
but a lot of people who are going to be like,
I'm not really sure,
but if I play you a really big song from that year,
it's going to take you right back to when you were 11 years old.
And there there's something special that AI can't do about identifying that.
Um,
but also there's so many people we're going to need Ai.
so I'm,
I'm interested to see what someone like yourself comes up with the next and
hopefully by the time you do,
I will be out of the music industry.
And I'm kidding.
Thank you.
Good though.
So a scooter,
uh,
what are your thoughts on blockchain technology?
Um,
my thoughts are blocked and blockchain technology is amazing and it's going to
be innovative in a hundred different industries,
uh,
but coins aren't needed in every single industry.
Um,
so I think having a coin associated to every piece of blockchain technology is
something that why 99% of the coins will disappear.
And the ones that make sense for the technology that they're associated with and
makes sense for the industry that they're going into will survive.
And those coins will be the Amazon of this bubble.
Um,
but I think that there's a very big difference between blockchain technology and
cryptocurrency,
in my opinion.
And,
uh,
I think that the actual use of blockchain,
blockchain technology,
it,
listen,
if they can break blockchain technology,
we're all screwed because that means that people can break our entire financial
system.
Um,
but I think it's going to make all of our systems more efficient.
Uh,
but I think that people should start educating himself on the difference between
Crypto and what blockchain is and,
and actually understand that it's way too easy to make coins and that's why most
of them should disappear.
But until then,
I'm going to have as much fun as you are.
Okay.
Off Road,
right in front of you.
Oh,
right there,
curator.
This has been awesome.
Thanks for common.
Um,
you're a tremendously successful entrepreneur across a range of industries,
tech,
nonprofits,
music,
media.
What excites you the most in your business?
Wow,
I'm really cheesy now that I'm a dad.
Um,
bedtime.
I mean honestly like,
uh
Huh.
I get excited by challenges and I get inside of by insults.
So when everyone is like,
oh,
you don't,
you don't so well I get really bored cause I don't know where to go.
Insults of usually lead me where to go because doing,
um,
the unreasonable thing has always led to the great thing.
Doing what everyone expects the status quo,
the reasonable,
it doesn't lead to any kind of greatest,
doesn't lead to a good story.
And I,
and I always said I wanted to,
you know,
be my own story instead of reading everyone else's.
Um,
but what gets me excited at this point?
Who hears a parent?
Okay.
So the people raise their hand are going to get this.
My Kid,
my three year old woke me up this morning,
slapped me in my forehead and said,
Daddy,
I love you
so much better than a grammy.
So much better than you know.
And I and IPO of,
you know,
it's,
there's no real describing it because you do all this stuff and you don't really
understand.
You're like,
what am I here for?
And then you have kids and then you understand who you actually are here for.
Um,
you have like a purpose when you have children that you just didn't have before
and there's no good time to have kids cause you're always planning your life and
seeing it through your own eyes.
And then when they finally show up,
you're like,
I don't really understand what life would have been without you.
Um,
yeah,
I know.
I sucked.
You guys are leaving.
You guys want to leave?
Yeah,
I know.
I saw Dave Chappelle do this one time at a con,
like the comedy store.
He did like a secret show.
People walked out and he did this.
Everyone give a round of applause cause they hate me.
Um,
uh,
I liked about what makes me excited is um,
either the first time I do something,
being with my family experienced something like that.
Or when someone I work with has a first you like if the first time I saw this
Guy Mike George who works for me,
receive as first platinum plaque in our company.
I had at that point in my career,
received a lot of platinum plaques.
They're in the garage.
Seeing him have the joy of that first time reminded me of what that felt like
and that gives me joy.
So I'm,
I'm kind of at a point now where I feel like my life is kind of absurd and I
have everything I've ever needed in a lot more.
And I only got there because I stood on the shoulders of all these people that
believed in me.
So now it's my turn to kind of work for them and make sure I pull them up to
where I'm at.
Awesome.
Thanks.
Uh,
so what was your response when Kanye was showed a kind of support for Donald
Trump?
I disagreed.
I mean a,
it's,
here's the thing,
living in Los Angeles,
I'm really grateful that I lived in Atlanta,
Georgia until six years ago.
I'm living in Los Angeles in New York.
Art is amazing.
At living in the states.
Amazing.
Cause it's probably the most forward state in the nation.
Um,
but we're not without fault.
There's the largest separation of wealth in the country is in the state.
And people acted like they lost their damn minds when he won.
And to me when he won,
I didn't freak out because that's the process.
Someone needs to win and then you're supposed to heal and come together.
A lot of things that he's done since have disappointed me to a place that I'm
not okay,
but I was going to give him a chance in the beginning.
Um,
cause I think that's the process.
And if you don't,
then you're a hypocrite if you're,
you know,
because if,
if Hillary would have won and they said,
oh,
we don't want to support her,
we would have been yelling at them.
Um,
so when he felt that way,
I said,
look,
that's your opinion.
But I also felt like he was that way when at a point where,
you know,
he was sick,
and I felt like there were old people around him.
It was very frustrating.
I thought we were taking advantage of a time where like if you saw Quincy Jones
most recent interview,
nobody should have let that person at the house at the time.
Like sometimes people need to be given privacy just because they're public
figures.
They need to be given a moment to process.
Um,
but,
uh,
I know his heart and I know that he's a human being then I don't always agree
with,
but I respect him and he said what he wanted to say and I'm allowed to have my
own opinion,
you know,
just cause I managed,
someone doesn't need me and I need to agree with them.
Me and Vic Mensa who I manage had a big disagreement recently and I was proud
that he put up on his Instagram.
He said,
I know scooter Braun vehemently disagreed with me and he's my manager,
but I appreciate him at least having a conversation.
I think we've messed up in this country and really around the world.
We've forgotten how to speak to each other and we're forgetting the same people
were yelling at other people.
We're claiming that we're supposed to help.
And I think we need to start having conversations out of respect again.
Otherwise nothing is going to change.
Cool.
You got to throw it all the way over there if the throw it.
Oh good catch.
I thought she was going to you.
She went deep.
You got to Kirk cousins arm.
So first of all,
I was a college student in Atlanta from 2002 to 2006 so I probably went to some
of your parties and didn't even note it.
Um,
but you mentioned about how you,
when you have success you get bored and you're kind of always looking for that
next challenge.
So is there something on the horizon for you that you feel like is some sort of
like moonshot thing that you'll think you'll go after next or is it just going
to be bringing up those people behind you and all of those things that are,
I think it's a combination.
If I want to bring them up then I got to keep going.
Um,
so
if the way I look at it,
here's the challenge,
I'm 36 years old.
He's like,
you got a cool story.
If this is the end of my story,
then I failed because I'm 36 the average entrepreneur hits their stride at 39.
So to me,
I'm just getting started.
So I don't know necessarily what it is next.
And I don't like talking about stuff before it happens.
So there's things working on.
But I also know part of my story is going to include failure.
Cause the last decade of my life has had so much success that statistically if
I'm really not being a moron in paying attention to a little data,
statistically I should have some serious failure on the horizon.
You know,
the Wall Street goes up,
it goes down.
There's always gotta be a correction.
So what I'm excited about is regardless of what that correction is,
it's not going to stop me.
It's just going to be a pitstop.
Um,
because now
we're the universe messed up is they gave me too much.
Now I've got my wife and kids,
I'm playing with house money.
So like you can't really take anything away from me.
Like,
if I lose some money or like lose some,
you know,
popular,
if,
if I dropped the ball,
some naysayers who wanted to see me fail for a while,
like,
ha ha,
I told you so,
they're going to be super disappointed when they find out I'm not that upset.
Um,
but I'm just going to keep going and see where it takes me and you know,
whatever comes next.
I'm ready for it.
And I,
and I,
I get bored,
but I also like,
I'm a workaholic.
I can't really shut it off.
Like the,
the hardest challenge for me is work life balance.
Like I'm constantly getting better,
but my wife,
she was the one who said to me,
she goes,
you know,
there's a difference between being present and being present and,
um,
that's the thing I'm working on the most at home,
putting the phone down and being present.
Good luck.
Thanks.
I hope you enjoy the party back in the day.
This has been awesome.
Uh,
I'm curious,
do you think you could have been as successful had you pursued a completely
different path?
Like,
how much of your success is attributable to your passion for,
for music and your craft as opposed to just your inherent drive?
I mean,
I don't know.
I know that I didn't go into life being like,
you know what?
I want to do music.
Um,
I just wanted to be an entrepreneur and that's the way I've always kind of
consider myself.
And I read a book about David Geffen where he said music was the fastest way in
because music takes a night and movies and TV and entertainment take years,
but at one song to change your life in a night.
And I was like,
ah,
I'm in Atlanta,
let's go.
Um,
but I,
uh,
I don't know what my life would have been.
I think there's so many points in my life.
I look back and think if I were to turn that way instead of that way,
what would have happened if I would've stayed in that relationship?
What would have happened?
Like,
you know,
there's so many different ways I look at it.
All I know is I thank God every day I wake up and this is where I ended up
because I'm 36 years old and whenever I get depressed,
the one thing I remind myself of this and I'm like,
if you put my life against any 36 year old on the planet,
I'm going to take my life.
Like I'm gonna choose this.
Like this is good stuff for 36 I'm working with this.
This is fine by me except for the jets.
We never,
when
I see you with the Steelers shirt,
sorry,
this is great.
And actually listened to you on Simmons as well.
So I'm one of your three basketball fans.
Nice.
Yeah.
That was fun with bill.
It was,
he's got to show up at my pickup game now.
Yeah.
And there's nice,
not too much overlap today.
I'm curious,
you said that you,
Facebook is kind of like the one that got away on the tech side.
Curious if there's something on the artist side.
Oh,
I saw this person that needs to come with me.
I got it.
Um,
I mean there's a bunch of different ones,
but I'm really,
it's like Facebook.
I don't have real regret.
I feel like it just lead me one way to another.
I mean,
a funny story is I knew Macklemore before he blew up.
We were friends and I knew about them in Seattle and um,
he had the mixed tape and it was just all the hits,
but it wasn't out yet.
And he sent it to me.
We were talking and I was just like,
is there any way I get you to sign,
you know,
over here?
And he said,
look,
the only person I would sign with his drink.
So I hit up Drake and I'm like,
you should do this.
And he's like,
okay,
hit.
And it tells me one of his guys,
you know,
to hit we trust on the HR side.
And um,
Drake and I weren't in business the way we are now.
Um,
but we were friends and his guy just didn't pay attention to past and went
Macklemore's album went number one.
They were like,
don't tell drink.
Um,
but it,
you know,
like I said,
I wake up and I looked at my life like I don't want to look back and have
regrets.
I think the only thing you should ever regret about is things that you do that
were malicious,
like missing out on stuff or anything like that.
Like I don't have regrets,
like that's part of the journey.
But if you do something malicious,
I'll tell you something I have regret about,
I was a basketball camp when I was in seventh grade or eighth grade,
like sleep away camp.
And these older kids a year older than me,
they were real cool.
They were like,
come hang with us cause I was,
I was good.
And they were like,
man,
this kid in our hall,
he's Dork user and I'm like,
don't work.
I'm a Dork,
but okay.
Um,
and they like broke into his room while he wasn't there and they put all his
shorts in the ground.
They're like,
Scooter pee on it.
And I knew it was wrong,
but these older kids were like,
peer pressure me and I peed on this poor kid's clothes.
And,
um,
we can't gets reported kids having to have to wear,
you know,
his bathing suit to play in,
stuff cause there's p and,
and I just felt so bad,
I was like screw these kids.
So I went up to him and I said,
I did this to you.
I'm so sorry.
Screw these kids are reported myself.
They didn't let me play in the All Star game even though I had made the all star
team at the end of the week.
And to this day,
even though I made it right,
kind of,
I never forgot that because I was like,
that's regret.
I knew better.
Like I shouldn't have done that.
But everything else in my life,
if I missed out,
I missed out.
I wasn't,
I didn't do anything bad.
Shouldn't peed on his clothes man
for seventh grade or does that also his mom?
He didn't tell his mom that we made good.
So I didn't tell my dad would happen.
He didn't understand why I was in the All Star game and the last day of camp,
the parents come and the mom,
I'm sitting there and she goes like,
you disgusting little kid.
How dare you be at my son's clothes?
And I'm like,
what?
And he's like,
no,
mom,
we're good now.
We're good.
And my dad's like,
what are you doing?
And I was like,
I don't,
I don't know dad.
And then,
and then he goes,
how dare you say my son?
And she goes,
he PDLs he did not tell him and all this.
He looks at me and I'm like,
and he goes,
oh,
you're dead.
And uh,
I just,
that was not a good interaction with my dad at that time.
Coach Brown was not happy with me.
A scooter.
A question.
Uh,
what our conversations at the dinner table like with your family?
the manuals tend to have very,
uh,
they bring their work to the table.
Uh,
I'm wondering,
um,
and their narrative reminds me a lot of your families as well.
So as curious if your family has a similar question,
do you want to know
like what it was like growing up or what is like next to the growing up?
Growing up?
Um,
it was very important.
My parents that we sat down at the table and had,
you know,
a family meal and my parents were nine to five because my dad was a coach and
then he was a dentist and my mom was an orthodontist.
So,
you know,
they can be home every single night kind of when work was done.
And it was always important for us to sit around the table and have a
conversation.
And me and my brother,
um,
were very competitive and like we'd get into fights because we only two years
apart.
But if we fought too much then dad got involved.
He was bigger and stronger and fights better.
Um,
but it was very much challenges,
you know,
extremely competitive challenges.
Me and my dad were definitely the loudest.
My mom,
when she spoke,
everyone shut up and listen cause she was like the quiet boss.
Like,
my dad would talk a lot,
but if my mom spoke,
it was like,
okay,
that's we're done now.
Um,
but it was always,
what did you do today?
Very competitive,
kind of pushing each other but also a tremendous amount of love.
Like it wasn't,
you know,
there was,
there was high praise.
We were appreciated for our achievements and we were always told every night
before we went to bed,
my dad used to come on a room as long as I can remember and say,
hey,
bronze are different.
And we were like,
what does that mean?
And he always say,
it doesn't mean you're better than anybody,
but you're different.
And I hold you to extraordinary standards cause I think you're extraordinary.
And after awhile you begin to believe the propaganda.
So we went into life just believing that we could do anything because he had
ingrained that into us.
What our conversations are like today,
uh,
is,
um,
Levi has,
uh,
it will usually say,
I,
uh,
Daddy,
mama go,
uh,
Jagger has a new song called onion man.
Uh,
the lyrics are onion,
man,
onion,
onion man,
onion man over and over and over again for about half an hour.
Um,
and then my wife and I are just trying to have a conversation while they're
awake and then we usually talk once we get them down asleep.
But I'm actually,
I'll tell you a good conversation about my wife because I haven't spoken about
her a lot today,
but I want to give you an understanding of why I'm the way I am.
Um,
so she didn't want to date me because I was in the entertainment industry and I
saw her ted talk on fuck cancer and it made me want to meet her.
Um,
and I had to trick her into a date when I found out she was single like a year
later.
Um,
as you do that,
well,
she thought she was going to drinks with a bunch of people and when she showed
up it was just me and I had my five,
my friend set it up.
Um,
and then like the first date,
like kind of fell in love pretty quickly.
And that was that.
Uh,
but now we're together for a while.
And I think some of you in this room might have heard that Justin Bieber had a
turbulent time in his life.
Um,
things weren't always so easy for the young man.
and that was a very,
very hard about a year and a half,
two years.
And one day,
you know,
he and some other clients were going through stuff and it was just like four
days of just really bad stuff.
And I was bringing it home night after night after night,
we're getting a ban,
I'm bringing it home.
And um,
she is just like,
look,
you can't keep bringing this to bed because I'm just like,
it's,
I'm,
I'm not getting any of you.
Like you gotta you gotta cut it off when we go to bed and in the Classic
Entertainment Prick move,
I respond with,
look,
you have to understand this is what I do for a living.
You don't appreciate what I do.
This is how I provide.
This is like,
this is how I'm able to do everything.
And my wife looks at me and she says,
okay,
cool.
You're right.
So I was helping someone with Chemo today I'm going to bring that to bed and um,
I shut up,
realized instantly and how much I loved her and said,
I love you so much.
Thank you.
Cause my wife is the number one person who introduced in my life the difference
between problems and inconveniences.
Hmm.
When we work in this world of tech or entertainment or wealth,
um,
you tend to think that what you're doing is very,
very important.
And 99% of the stuff I deal with is inconveniences,
high class inconveniences,
but inconveniences and what my wife deals with his problems and I think she
taught me the difference.
So it's given me perspective.
Awesome.
To throw it
good.
You guys are very athletic.
Everyone has perfect throws.
No one's dropped
first to sign up to the jets.
Yeah.
And we meet you.
I appreciate you being very honest and candid and not scripted.
I like all the stories you've been telling.
Um,
so a lot of people like the entertainment industry and all its fame and glory
and wealth and a lot of people want to stay far away from it because of all the
egos.
Um,
in your journey through the entertainment industry,
what have you learned to really like about it and what have you really hated
about it?
Um,
what I like about it is most of the stuff I would do that I get paid for,
I would actually do for free.
I like to be able to go to a show or help someone make a record or make a TV
show or a film or you know,
you know,
advise someone on a tactic.
Like that's fun.
You know,
most of that stuff I would do for free.
The bullshit is what I get paid for.
You know,
the stuff that I hate,
the inconvenience first prompts and people not understanding the difference.
Um,
but the hardest part,
uh,
is that answer the good part.
Good.
Well enough.
Um,
and also like you're in an elevator or when you're in a restaurant and the
background music is a record that you are a part of,
that's actually a really cool feeling because like you're not really paying
attention and you're like,
why do I know this?
And all of a sudden you're like,
oh,
I helped put this together.
That's pretty damn cool.
Um,
or I just made 25 cents because I have the publisher.
uh,
the hard part is knowing your truth,
you know,
[inaudible] and I think it's highlighted entertainment because it's so high
profile.
But knowing your truth is really the hard part because people that even I think,
no,
my character that I've gotten to know me have been like,
you know,
because of their own issues or whatever,
they will like call you out on your truth and say,
well,
I think like you're,
you're in it for the wrong reasons or,
you know,
I,
they'll,
they'll kind of puts you down.
They'll,
they'll project their negativity onto you.
Um,
and because I decided early on,
okay,
I want to build a brand that I can build off of.
I did put a target on my back and having to know who I am and what I stand for
and what I believe in and who I love and who loves me has been the greatest
challenge of holding onto that.
So I don't get lost in other people's expectations and not even expectations.
Their projections of what they want to see to make themselves feel better.
Um,
and understanding that you don't have to be friends with everybody.
You can be polite to everyone.
It can be kind to everyone,
but you're not going to change someone if they want to project that negativity
on to you.
You have to just be okay with it and know it's not your truth.
And,
and in my industry it's very,
very hard sometimes to not get lost in the amount of negativity that exists.
People want it.
They're not happy for each other.
They want to break each other down.
They don't want it.
They want to count your money or your success and hope that you fail.
And um,
right before we got on the stage,
I was joking cause we were talking about,
you know,
people's success and I said,
look,
my thing is I hope everyone's successful because I don't want to pay for your
vacation.
I want to,
I want to go on vacation with you and I want you to pay for your own vacation.
Like,
do you know what it's like to bring friends on vacation?
They can't pay for the vacation.
It's very frustrating.
So yeah,
I'm,
I'm telling you like if Sally,
we can go on vacation together and everybody stands on their own too.
It's great.
So I don't really,
I want everyone to be successful.
I really like,
one of my buddies just launched his own company and finally left an agency after
still,
I think 12 years.
I couldn't be happier for him.
Like I'm rooting for him from the top.
And originally he wanted to come in and I was going to get 50% of the company
and funded and then he changed his mind and goes,
look,
you'll be my first investor if I need it,
but I don't think I need funding right now.
And another friend who was like,
are you upset?
I was like,
no,
he's doing what's right for him.
Like I want him to win and at the end of the day,
if he becomes successful,
he buys dinner.
Oh,
I think it's just not getting lost in,
that's the hardest thing.
You got to throw it all out.
You got this,
you got this,
you got this?
Yes.
Wow.
I'm telling you,
I had a ball.
I'm British,
so we don't,
we don't couch things.
We just run away.
Use your feet.
Big Fates.
Hold arms.
It's interesting hearing you talk because you said you've always wanted to be an
entrepreneur,
but when the way you talk about your life,
it doesn't seem like your primary goal has ever really been about business or
about money.
It sounds as though you've wanted to go on a journey that's allowed you to
uncover what is valuable in life for you.
And now you've reached that point.
Would you say that's true or,
yeah,
but um,
you guys got me a little time of somebody's life story.
It's so when I was a kid,
we moved from uh,
like the Bible Street Park area to this house,
like out in the boonies.
And this guy from Greenpeace showed up at the door and um,
he asked us for money,
explain everything and I was like,
oh,
this is amazing.
It's going to save the world.
And I went and got,
my mom was like,
we should write him a check.
And she's like,
look,
we give to charities,
but they can't just give money to every single person.
We got to pay bills and put food on the table.
And I was like,
no mom,
it's amazing Kim,
a check.
So I convinced my mom to give him like whatever check it was 25,
50 bucks,
like to support Greenpeace.
And he starts to leave and I'm like,
where's his car?
And my mom was like,
he doesn't have a car.
Part of the cause he's walking from house to house because he supporting the
environment.
And I was like,
but we don't live near a bus station or train station.
Like he's going to be walking four miles.
And my mom's like,
yeah,
that's part of it.
And I was like,
this guy's amazing.
But in that moment I was like,
if my mom doesn't write him a check,
he's just a dude walking from house to house.
He's too reliant on the check.
And I always like to figure out ways to skip steps.
And that was when I realized very young that money was an avenue to freedom.
And as I got older and got to witness a lot of people with money,
I realize a lot of people don't understand that and it ends up trapping them
even more.
But I think being an entrepreneur allows me to do everything that you're
describing.
Um,
and that's why I've always wanted to have financial freedom and success because
I don't want ever want to be limited or have my dreams or my passions or my
wants.
For this world to be blocked because I can't get a check from someone.
Um,
and I'm seeing it now,
like we did the telephone last year called hand in hand where we raised money
for the victims of the hurricane and being able to go out and do that because of
the power I had as an entrepreneur.
That was liberating.
Um,
and then people gave money.
but it's,
uh,
I agree with you.
I don't,
I think if I didn't look at it that way,
if I,
the word entrepreneur is funny cause you know,
we think,
oh,
it's someone who wants to make a ton of money,
but I ask that person what they want to do with the money,
you know,
and if they don't know what they want to do with the money,
I think there are pretty shitty
entrepreneur.
I just know what I want to do with it.
I want to,
you know,
provide for my family and my friends and I want to be able to make an impact in
the world.
Cause at a hundred years,
no one's going to remember me.
I don't think anyone,
no one's gonna remember any of us,
to be honest with you 100 years.
But I think they'll feel our impact.
So I want to be able to have as much capital as I need to create impact.
Does that answer it?
All right guys,
that might've been the,
the like realist best interview I've been a part of for toxic Google.
So over my brother.
I kind of implied that.
I'm not saying it explicitly,
but
I just like repeating it.
Like I said,
we're very competitive.
Uh,
by the way I did before I leave.
Um,
would you mind standing up?
Yes,
please.
Turn around everyone please.
He put together a wonderful outfit today and I want you to go around with loss.
Give it up with Sanjay.
Yes.
Thank you.
It is not that cold.
Oh,
this is fun.
It's good.
Thank you so much.
Going to give it up.
Got It.